we have breaking news from London where
British Prime Minister Theresa May has
just announced in an emotional
appearance that she will resign in two
weeks time the second female prime
minister but certainly not the last I do
so with no ill will but with enormous
and enduring gratitude to have had the
opportunity to serve the country I love
May has failed to carry out Briggs it
though not without trying that is
Britain's voter-approved exit from the
European Union
MTS taya is outside 10 Downing Street
the Prime Minister's house in London MTS
did you expect to be standing there this
morning we certainly did we kind of
heard something was going to happen this
morning but then we saw it resume
walking out here making that emotional
speech and I gotta say Tony it's not
often you see a British Prime Minister
in tears but that's just what we saw
Theresa May of course announcing that
she will be stepping down on June the
7th as Prime Minister
she started her speech by saying you
know she'd done her best that she tried
three times to deliver brexit adding it
was rights to persevere
she also appealed for compromise saying
you know it wasn't a dirty word now
leadership contest for the ruling
Conservative Party will soon be underway
one of the leading contenders is the
former London Mayor Boris Johnson who's
a firm supporter of brexit but whoever
moves into 10 Downing Street their job
will be to negotiate that divorce from
the European
it's something charissa may fail to do
and it's something that fur times prime
minister will be defies yeah you could
tell it's a very tough morning for her
thank you very much empty has taya
reporting from 10 Downing Street